fast Texas surprise cameos left
audiences rocked does this Herald a new
direction for the franchise's end or
does it Mark a return to the fast
family's Roots spoilers ahead
the off-screen Rivalry between Vin
Diesel and Dwayne Johnson is no secret
after starring on three franchise
installments together Johnson returned
once more for the eighth feature the
fate of the Furious following the film's
release of both Johnson and Diesel
alluded to some serious onset tension
that continued to Bubble into the
production of the next installments but
instead of continuing to start opposite
one another Johnson was given the Reigns
to the first and only Fast and Furious
spin-off Hobbs and sure where he starred
opposite Jason Statham diesel continued
on with F9 which neglected to even
mention Hobbes though Statham sure
appeared in a mid-credit scene despite
the high tensions between these two Mega
Stars Johnson returns to the franchising
of post-credits Cameo for fast X after
2019's Hobson Shore and Johnson's
previous comments about not returning to
the fast family many thought the
character was gone for good things
seemed especially dire when Johnson
ignored Diesel's social media peace
offering when he asked the former WWE
Superstar to return to the franchise for
the sake of the fans with hobb's return
maybe the few between Johnson and Diesel
is finally over over due to their past
it's unlikely that Johnson would work
with diesel again if things off screen
hadn't changed giving us hope for Fast
and Furious 11. with Fast and Furious
presents Hobson Shore Johnson and
Statham showed their character's
potential to headline a major motion
picture without Diesel's Dom Toretto and
family in fact the film expanded on The
Fast and Furious Universe introducing
the Techno terrorist organization etian
a superhuman Brixton law and the
extended families of both titular action
heroes while these additions might not
seem like much outside of the context of
Hobson Shore there's a possibility that
they may have some serious ramifications
on the franchise at large especially as
Johnson and Statham returned to Mainline
the fast Saga since the introduction of
Kurt Russell's Mr Nobody in Furious 7
the franchise has shifted from street
races and extensive car highs to Global
Espionage and weld ending threats Hobbs
ensure was no different revealing that
etyan is in control of many of the
world's media Outlets with goals of
global domination since Hobbes left the
terretto crew to continue enforcing law
and order elsewhere bringing some of
that back with him isn't out of the
question though ETI hasn't shown up in
the fast Saga yet the return of Hobbes
could reveal that he's on the criminal
organization's tail especially after the
mysterious director's threats
you will likewise the introduction of
hub's extended family of Warriors and
his spin-off feature may end up
fattering into the 11th installment
somehow after all this franchise is
about family that said it might be a bit
jarring for the events of a spin-off
film to factor into the swan song of a
franchise 10 Mainline movies deep so
we'll just have to wait and see
ing of Hobbs and Shore initial sequel
talks were had following the release of
The Fast and Furious spin-off but we
haven't heard much about the
continuation since though Johnson seems
confident that another installment would
be made it seems as if the folks at
Universal Pictures have been hyper
focused on closing out the fast Saga
first with 2021's F9 and 2023's fast X
both coming out since Johnson and
Statham's body flick it's clear that the
Studio's priorities lie elsewhere at
least for now in 2022 producer Kelly
McCormick confirmed to comicbook.com
although they'd love to make another
Hobson Shore in the future there are
Quotes no conversations at this time but
that was then and this is now with
Johnson's return for Fast Tax and likely
the 11th fast Saga film as well maybe
this is The Rock's way of reigniting
interest in his character after a few
years of Silence no doubt after the box
office bomb that was Black Adam
Johnson's Venture into the DC Comics
superhero space the mega star is likely
attempting to revisit his known
successes since his time as Luke Hobbs
has always led to highbox office returns
coming back to the fast Saga it seems
like the right move has are failing to
restructure the hierarchy of power in
the DC Universe
since Johnson's departure following the
fate of the Furious the series has
brought along another WWE Champion into
their ranks in F9 John Cena serves as a
primary antagonist playing Dom toretto's
long-lost brother Jacob over the course
of the film Dom and Jacob May commends
leading to the latter's return for fast
X in which he helps save his nephew from
Dom's latest antagonist Dante Reyes
though Jacob seemingly gives his life
for his family it's hard to say what the
future holds after all even death can't
stop characters from returning to the
terretto family again and again all that
is to say Jacob and Hobbs played by two
WWE Legends they finally meet in the
Fast and Furious franchise with the way
fastx on his previous franchise
installments and the occasionally
non-linear nature of the fast Saga as a
whole it's entirely possible that Luke
Hobbs and Jacob Toretto could have met
some time in the not too distant past or
maybe even the Fast and Furious
franchise isn't big enough for two WWE
Heroes that coexist in it at the same
time
in his fourth outing 2009's Fast and
Furious the series returned to its
street racing and criminal rules
reuniting Vin Diesel's dumb and Paul
Walker's Brian for a brand new adventure
then when 2011's Fast 5 was released the
franchise was reborn through a series of
extensive Heights and new cast members
who helped rebuild the series into
something bigger and better Dwayne
Johnson was one of those cast members
and his character Luke Hobbs introduced
to opportunities to the Toretto crew and
kept them racing for years in fact to
Hobbs is a guy to take out Fast Five
antagonist Hernan Reyes so bringing the
rock back for fast X itself a direct
continuation of Fast 5 only makes sense
as Jason momoa's Dante Reyes plans to
destroy those who killed his father fast
X reveals that Hobbes likewise is a
target however the 11th installment
shapes up the events of Fast Five
considered one of the best in the
franchise while still propelling the
overall series plot forward by bringing
Hobbes back it shows that the filmmakers
behind the multi-part finale are hoping
to honor the franchise to its core
giving each and every character their
due diligence he is hoping that more
familiar faces will return for fast and
Furious 11. for years the name Dwayne
Johnson has brought in the big bucks
between his chiseled features and
intense Charisma the former WWE star
certainly knows how to entertain a
diverse crowd having vented into
comedies action films superhero
Productions and animated features there
are very few genres that The Rock hasn't
attempted to break into sure he's had
some bombs along the way but generally
speaking franchises like Fast and
Furious and Jumanji have been massive
hits for the wrestler turned movie star
to this day Furious 7 is still the
actor's highest grossing picture having
brought in 1.5 billion dollars worldwide
no wonder he'd eventually make a furious
comeback with the series has brought in
the most success we're just surprised
that he didn't do it faster that is
gonna work needless to say Johnson's
four fast Sago installments and his
Hobbs ensure solovenger have done
tremendously well bringing in new
audiences along the way with Johnson's
return to the franchise plus the
additional novelty of these films being
the beginning of the end for the series
as we know it the likelihood of high box
office returns is high
recent Fast and Furious installments
have made it a point to highlight the
children of the most popular characters
in the series in fate of the Furious
Adam was introduced to his son with
Elena who he later named Brian similarly
Hobbs and Shaw highlights hobb's
daughter Sam and Brian and Mia's
children are mentioned on more than one
occasion throughout the last few films
yes found family is the Bedrock of the
fast Saga but the Next Generation
matters too in fact the non-canon
Animated Series Fast and Furious spy
Racers is all about a younger generation
of operatives led by Dom's cousin Tony
as they use fast cars to save the world
by bringing hubs back into the fold and
giving fast action emphasis on fathers
and their children Johnson's return
might Mark a new era for the fast Saga
while the story of Dom's crew may end
soon that doesn't mean the Fast and
Furious franchise would officially Fade
to Black instead it's possible that a
new series featuring The Toretto gang's
kids may be developed in the future
since the end of Fast Five this
franchise has made it clear that death
isn't the end for many of our recurring
heroes from Letty survival after her
apparent murder in the fourth film to
Han surviving his explosive end in Tokyo
Drift there's no telling who could come
back in the future even characters like
Sean Boswell from Tokyo Drift who made
his return via a cameo in Furious 7
before officially reappearing in F9 find
themselves reuniting the Dominus crew at
some point down the line with that in
mind Johnson's return as hubs as
unlikely as it seemed isn't exactly
surprising after fast decks it's a
wonder who else might return in the
future the final chapters of the fast
Saga shouldn't be overstuffed but Hobbes
re-entering the family means the door is
open for other characters to get back
behind the wheel
in the past Dwayne Johnson has received
top billing for his Fast and Furious
appearances alongside Vin Diesel and
Paul Walker though the lure clearly the
stars of the franchise Johnson has
dodgedly attempted to carve out a clear
slice of the fast Saga pie from South no
doubt this led to the initial feud
between Johnson and Diesel but now that
the hatchet seems to be buried there may
be hope for fans who want to see more of
hubs well Johnson's return could very
well lead to more Hobson Shore movies
going forward it's not necessarily
impossible that Harps Johnson could take
center stage in future Fast and Furious
movies since Hobbes already tried that
during the fate of the Furious it
wouldn't be a surprise to see him
leading the group going forward
obviously no one can replace Dom but
that doesn't mean that the Fast and
Furious brand couldn't live on without
him always here diesel then the Pirates
all in full walk sequel Too Fast Too
Furious and he only had a small cameo in
Tokyo Drift admittedly there hasn't been
a second Mainline fast saga movie yet
that doesn't feature diesel in some
capacity but it's at least a possibility
that Johnson could carry the Fast and
Furious torch once Dom's story is
finally done
foreign